[Instrumental]
Salut ! Y'a quelques temps à la Vidéo City Paris j'ai rencontré l'inventeur de cet instrument.
Il a appelé ça le dualo, c'est un truc un peu ouf qui permet de faire de la musique même quand t'y connais rien.
Je lui ai donc proposé de passer nous faire une démo.
Et surtout pour comprendre le processus créatif qui l'a amené à inventer ça.
Restez bien jusqu'au bout de la vidéo j'ai un truc sympa à vous dire à la fin.
Et en parlant de la fin, n'oubliez pas qu'on a un nouveau rituel ensemble
Sur les 2 dernières secondes de la vidéo, j'vous mets un panneau où vous retrouvez les prochaines dates de dédicaces du livre,
la date de la prochaine vidéo, la date du prochain live et d'autres infos quand il y a d'autres infos.
- Ça Fabien tu peux le faire si tu veux
- C'est vrai ?
- Ouais, tu veux essayer ?
- Ouais j'veux bien essayer
On a trouvé l'objet le plus satisfaisant du monde c'est pas un handspinner
C'est ça l'objet le plus satisfaisant du monde mon gars !
J'ai des étoiles dans les yeux quand tu joues quoi !
Okay alors je l'enregistre... J'appuie là
Là ça s'enclenche direct et tout.
[Instrumental]
- Bon là c'est la première fois que tu joues t'as pas trop l'habitude y'a pas de soucis.
Et maintenant on va faire la basse
- Okay
[Explications, touches, boutons etc.]
[Shape of you]
- Bah sache que les démos qu'il y a sur YouTube si tu bosses une petite après-midi tu peux les refaire.
Surtout que sur le dualo, ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est une communauté de joueurs (Tu peux baisser le son si tu veux comme ça)
- Comme ça ? Roh c'est génial !
- Voilà et en fait sur dualo il y a toute une communauté de joueurs
Et ce qu'on fait, dès qu'on fait un morceau, le morceau c'est un fichier qui est là dedans.
Et du coup on le partage sur internet
Et n'importe qui peut le télécharger le mettre dedans.
On partage des sons aussi, ce morceau là par exemple il est sur notre site.
Si tu veux refaire shape of you, tu le télécharges, tu télécharges des sons qui vont avec tu les mets sur le dualo
Et après tu les refais à ta sauce.
- Comment est ce que ça t'es venu de créer ça ?
Peut-être pas l'objet tel qu'il est fini aujourd'hui mais en tout cas ta base d'idée c'était quoi ?
- Alors à la base c'était ... Déjà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que moi je suis musicien amateur.
- Ouais
- Mais fanfaron, donc j'ai fait de la fanfare pendant 10 ans
Je faisais du trombone bon voilà.
Et ce qui me faisait kiffer dans la fanfare c'est que je jouais à 50 cm des gens.
Je me disais : mais pourquoi les notes sont disposées comme ça sur un piano .
Puis je me demandais s'il n'y avait pas plus malin.
Et j'étais inspiré par l'instrument qui s'appelle la sanza.
- Okay
- La sanza c'est un instrument africain
C'est typiquement le genre d'instrument que t'offres à quelqu'un quand tu sais pas quoi lui offrir
Quelqu'un qui est musicien tu sais pas quoi lui offrir, tu lui offres une sanza.
En Afrique, on utilise des gammes pentatoniques
C'est des gammes à 5 notes
Et en Europe on utilise des gammes à 7 notes : do ré mi fa sol la si do
Comptez bien il y en a 7
Et elles sont disposées de façon euh..
alternatives
En gros, c'est disposé comme ça : do ré mi fa sol la si do
Voilà, ça c'est la gamme. La gamme, on la coupe en 2 comme ça
Du coup là, on a une note sur 2
Et en musique, croyez-moi sur parole, en musique
si on prend une note sur deux ça fait un accord
Donc du coup la découverte est là
J'avais ça sous mes mains : j'avais un accord dans la main droite, un accord dans la main gauche
Et du coup bah tiens tu vas le faire
Les notes qui sont les unes à côté des autres, c'est les notes des accords
Et donc dès que tu fais 3 touches d'affilées ça sonne bien
Donc tant que tu joues sur les touches qui sont allumées t'es sûr que ça sonne
(Il joue)
Et du coup là Fabien on va faire la gamme donc tu
-Je.. compose La Lettre à Elise okay..
Et maintenant ce que tu vas faire c'est que tu vas alterner à gauche à droite
Donc index/index, majeur/majeur vas-y
(Il compose la gamme)
Voilà, et maintenant refais la même chose sans toucher les.. les touches.. voilà
(Il joue)
Fabien : Parfait
Toi, tu as, tu as réadapté du coup toutes les couleurs, à chaque fois il y a juste à suivre en fait
Il y a juste à suivre ouais
Et t'affiches la gamme que tu veux..
Donc si tu veux jouer en.. j'sais pas moi, en gamme orientale
Tu mets la gamme orientale, et tu joues dessus ça sonnera oriental
Voilà du coup, les accords c'est des dessins, les gammes c'est des dessins, du coup c'est hyper visuel comme clavier.
Et voilà, et le pari en fait c'est que nous on est des homo sapiens, les homo sapiens ils ont une mémoire plutôt visuelle
Et bah du coup c'est un instrument qui est fait pour nous quoi.
Moi, je vais voir pas mal de concerts de hip-hop, d'électro
Et je trouves ça dommage, à chaque fois les DJ ils sont comme ça sur la table
Avec leur casque là et tu les vois tourner les boutons mais t'entends pas ce que ça fait.
Mais du coup là ce que je voulais c'est que ce soit un instrument où le public voit ce qu'il se passe.
Donc là si tu joues comme un shredder par exemple, bah là les mecs ils vont capter
Ils vont dire : "Oh putain Fabien il déchire il joue trop vite et tout"
Ou alors si ils voient que tu es en train d'appuyer là bah ils voient que tu es en train de choisir un son ..
- Oui c'est ça, moi quand je te regarde jouer ou quand je vous regarde jouer sur le net
J'vois toute la chorée en fait
- Tu vois ce qu'il se passe.
- Et du coup t'as le show même à regarder la personne jouer, c'est beau bah contrairement à un DJ
Pour le coup, comme tu dis tu vois pas ce qu'il fait de ses mains réellement quoi, tu vois
- Et c'est dommage parce qu'il y a des DJ ils font vraiment des choses extraordinaire en terme de .. instrumental.
Mais ils le partagent pas avec leur public
Là l'idée c'est de partager le jeu musical avec le public.
Je trouve que c'est un objet satisfaisant en soi parce que à partir du moment où t'arrives à faire de la création sur un domaine de compétence que tu as pas toi.
Tu vois là en l’occurrence la musique, c'est comme si demain quelqu'un invente un truc qui me fait bien dessiner, tu vois ça va me rendre dingue.
T'as toujours l'impression qu'un instrument si tu le maîtrises pas assez convenablement t'en feras rien alors que là tu peux assez, on va dire t'amuser assez rapidement
Si tu retiens les principes, le fait que ce soit des dessins, le fait que tout soit en visuel, le fait que ce soit éclairé que t'aies tes débuts de gammes.
Nous ici, je sais déjà que vous le savez qu'on a une mémoire visuelle, parce qu'on en parle tous les 2 jours sur cette chaîne
Mais du coup c'est hyper adapté. La preuve, je vous promets que j'avais jamais essayé avant, mais vraiment jamais.
A part regarder les vidéos en badant et en me disant : "Ouais mais ça je pourrai jamais le faire" tu vois.
C'est comment tu peux avoir une idée de départ sur un instrument africain et arriver à ça.
- Ouais alors, je vais t'expliquer parce que, du coup à la base y'a la disposition des notes ça je t'ai raconté.
Donc en fait, je sais pas si t'as déjà fais une vidéo là dessus
Mais autant le coup de foudre je sais pas si ça existe, autant le "Eurêka" ça je peux témoigner ça existe.
J'ai eu cette idée là en fait c'est 2 ans plus tard où je l'ai vraiment scindée dans ma tête
Avec tout ce réseau hexagonal
Il était 4h du matin je me suis réveillé en sueur et je me suis précipité sur mon ordi, j'ai dessiné ce clavier, je l'ai imprimé
Et j'ai joué toute la nuit sur la table comme ça à faire "touc touc" et à réveiller ma copine d'ailleurs enfin bref.
Toutes les idées sont arrivées très naturellement et en 3 semaines j'avais dans ma tête l'objet qui était là.
Les idées c'est facile, c'est vraiment facile.
En fait là, j'ai vraiment eu l'impression de tirer une pelote de laine.
C'est à dire que j'avais une nouvelle disposition des notes
Du coup, bon bah naturellement on se dit faut le mettre sur un instrument
Naturellement tu te dis bah on va faire un design nouveau puisque le clavier est nouveau
Donc bah à l'époque c'était en 2007 tu vois, donc tu te dis bah qu'est ce qu'on rêve d'avoir
Bah un truc où le public il voit ce qu'on joue, un truc où y'a un petit écran pour bien capter, un truc où y'a pas besoin d'ordinateur, où on peut faire des boucles
Voilà, et toutes ces idées s’enchaînent petit à petit
Et du coup, j'ai un peu écrit la lettre au père noël de l'instrument idéal. C'est quoi l'instrument idéal, toutes ces propriétés là.
Et après mon travail ça a été de trouver le design le plus simple possible qui permette d'intégrer tout ça.
Donc là vous vous en rendez peut-être pas compte en fait, mais cet instrument fait la même chose que les gros synthés arrangeur Yamaha
Qui sont gros comme ça et qui coûtent 4 000 balles, voilà.
Mais juste, moi j'suis un fan d'Apple, donc je voulais qu'il y ait le moins possible de boutons quoi.
Alors c'est vrai que je les ai pas amenées là mais mes premières maquettes il y avait plein de potards de partout
Il y avait plein de fils et tout, et puis petit à petit j'ai essayé de remplacer les boutons
Et une idée qui a été euh déterminante pour ça, c'est d'utiliser en fait les touches du clavier qui sont déjà là
Chaque touche correspond à un son et y'a le nom marqué à l'écran.
- Et en plus c'est très agréable car c'est très discret. J'ai jamais percuté dans toutes les vidéos que j'ai vu des gens qui s'en servent
Qu'ils checkaient un écran ici. C'est magnifique, je suis ravi en fait en réalité y'a rien à gagner en fait, c'est pas un placement de produit
J'ai eu la chance qu'on se soit contacté après s'être rencontré à la vidéo city cette année et euh
Et je trouve l'ensemble du projet ouf c'est à dire, on parlait de la créativité
Pour moi la créativité c'est que t'as accès au futur dans ta tête mais après y'a le comment tu vas le mettre en place qui est génial
Comment tu vas aboutir à la meilleure version de ton idée euh et après y'a la musique et l'instrument en lui même
Et comme j'suis geek, enfin tu vois toi tu parlais des notes mais moi j'ai l'impression que tout se regroupe dans un objet
D'une j'vous félicite toute l'équipe (-merci), toi je te félicite d'avoir eu cette idée et de l'avoir emmenée au bout
Je trouve que c'est l'objet qu'il faut connaître aujourd'hui et j'espère qu'il y aura de plus en plus de gens qui feront des vidéos là dessus.
Je sais que Youtunes, Jordan, il a fait un truc déjà (- Ouais), j'trouve ça trop bien. Moi c'était une chance de pouvoir  vous rencontrer et de pouvoir l'essayer.
J'trouve ça ouf, bravo.
- Bah écoute, merci à toi et puis bah comme tu dis hésitez pas à en parler autour de vous.
[Démo]
- Voix de Fabien : La bonne nouvelle de la fin de cette vidéo c'est que depuis qu'on a tourné, on a discuté ensemble
Et on s'est mis d'accord sur un truc, au mois de septembre à la rentrée, on vous fera gagner au moins un instrument, un dualo pour vous.
J'vous tiendrai bien sûr au courant de tout ça sur les réseaux sociaux.
[Démo toujours]
- Voix de Fabien : Comme toujours si la vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas de la liker et de vous abonner et à très bientôt, ciao.
[Démo encore]